[Music]
Shadowhunters has been surrounded by a
storm of controversy since the beginning
starting with the author of the book we
discovered 10 dark secret Shadowhunters
doesn't want you to know and they are
pretty juicy watch until the end to see
what fans had to say about a love scene
that they may have crossed the line if
you're new here be sure to like our
video and subscribe to the things
channel to be the first to see our new
videos now check out these dark secrets
Shadowhunters doesn't want you to know
Kate McNamara found out she got the
starring role moments before it was
posted on Twitter Kat was feeling a bit
bummed because she hadn't heard anything
about whether or not she rented a
starring role of Clary
she knew that freeform which was a VC
family at the time was about to announce
the cast on Twitter she hadn't heard
anything so she assumed she didn't get
the part she decided to go to the gym to
take her mind off of it she thought that
seeing the explosion happening on
Twitter would make not getting the role
even worse little did she know her phone
was about to ring with news that would
completely change her career ten minutes
before they were about to announce the
cast on Twitter she got the call from
her team telling her she got the part
she was obviously ecstatic but her
excitement gave way to embarrassment
when she realized she was going to have
to rush over to ABC Family in her sweaty
workout clothes to start social media
promotions Kat said she was embarrassed
but that didn't last for very long
because she was thrilled to be cast in
the show she said she was floored and
honored to be a part of this amazing
ride still ABC probably should have
given her a bit more notice don't you
think plagiarism controversy did you
know that the author of the book series
which the Shadowhunters TV show is based
on has been in hot water in the past for
plagiarism
here are the deets the author whose real
name is Judith burr melts wrote some
juicy fanfiction from 2002 around 2006
under the pen name Cassandra Clare it
focused on a hot brooding version of
Harry Potter's Draco Malfoy it was
called the draco trilogy she became a
major influence in the Harry Potter
fanfiction world with her hit stories
titled Draco dorm Ian's Draco sinister
and Draco Vanitas that is until the
backlash
began members of the fanfiction
community started pointing out that
Claire was using direct quotes from
Buffy the Vampire Slayer and Babylon one
fan thick member in particular said she
was using unattributed phrases which
were taken from the out of print book
the hidden lands by Pamela Dean after
that Claire was bands from
fanfiction.net some people even accused
Cassandra Clare of cyberbullying her
critics though there doesn't seem to be
any proof of that once Claire got a book
deal for The Mortal Instruments her
publishing company removed all of her
fanfiction from the internet and changed
the spelling of her pen name
it seems she wanted fans to forget the
whole thing the movie flopped before
Shadowhunters became a TV show they came
out with a movie based on the y-a novels
it was called The Mortal Instruments
City of Bones let's just say it didn't
do well among critics and it completely
failed at the box office it only got
thirteen percent on Rotten Tomatoes ouch
the Boston Globe said it played like a
scary movie parody many said the
storyline was hard to follow and even
more critics called at mundane and
derivative of Harry Potter and Twilight
tuck crowd Cassandra Clare came under
fire again for bragging about how
satisfied she was with the adaption of
her book partly because of her input
into the filmmaking process and partly
because of the fans but then she changed
her tune after the box office numbers
and bad reviews came out she posted on
Twitter that she thought people were
having a hard time understanding how
little control authors have over film
adoptions of their books many people
thought her change in attitude made it
appear that she jumped ship when the
waters got choppy it's got to be hard to
hear critics say that the film Stine
but do you think it's fair of her to
distance herself from the film after it
got bad reviews the pilot got shaky
reviews so after they decided to switch
from adapting the books into films and
opted for the small screen instead they
shot the pilot for Shadowhunters the New
York Times said that Shadowhunters could
use a little of the humor of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer or the camp sense of True
Blood which it also echoes as the
baddies have a taste for the stuff in
mundane veins
the New York Times went on to say that
it's too Moody and self-serious
for a Popey action show in which
monsters dissolve into hot sparks when
stabs the NYT also states that a part of
the problem
the scripts and part is performance the
dialogue is sometimes written more
sassily than it's delivered as Clara
tells Jace she's not interested in being
part of his supernatural Fight Club
so is she kidding the New York Times
wants to know and so do we the end of
the review by saying that Shadowhunters
has its assets especially its popular
source material but that it might become
more fun if it learns to enjoy being the
empowerment fantasy it really is they
also mentioned that battling the
infernal army of the Knights may be a
dangerous burden but it beats having a
curfew not the best review in the world
but hey it beats earlier movie reviews
Dominic Sherwood's Geisler apparently
Dominic Sherwood who plays the role of
Jason Shadowhunters had to make a major
apology for using a homophobic slur on a
Facebook live video last year in the
video fans heard Dominic greeting his
co-star Matthew daddario with the gay
slur Matthew you play as a gay character
on the show told Dominic to stop because
they were live talking to fans
apparently Dominic didn't know that the
fans were listening to every word he
said live and in real time
oopsie-doopsie Dominic this guy had to
do some serious damage control he posted
an apology video on Instagram in which
he called his own behavior disgusting he
said he was making the video to hold
himself accountable and not to make any
excuses in any way he said that the way
he behaved was disgusting and that his
co-star Matt's reaction was an
absolutely correct one of disgust he
said he thinks so many problematic
phrases go unchallenged and they
perpetuate hatin intolerance he added
that his slur made him part of the hate
and intolerance and that he was truly
sorry but that everyone bought his
apology when Vann tweeted that his
behavior was absolutely revolting what
do you think should he be forgiven or
not the lawsuit in 2016 the author of
the Shadowhunter books found herself in
trouble again this time an author by the
name of sherrilyn kenyon who wrote the
dark hunter book series sued Cassandra
Clare for stealing her work sherrilyn
kenyon filed a lawsuit alleging that
Clare committed acts of trademark
infringement copyright infringement
unfair competition Faust advertising and
trade dress infringement Kenyon said she
lost profits because she believes Clare
willfully copied her dark-hunter series
in her lawsuit she claims that in
respects the elements of both book
franchises are virtually identical hmm
let's see
dark hunter and shadow hunters she may
have a point
don't you think Kenyon pointed out more
similarities when she said that both the
dark hunter series and the shadow hunter
series are about an elite band of
warriors that must protect the human
world from the unseen paranormal threats
that seeks to destroy humans as they go
about their daily lives she also noted
the uncanny similarities between the two
when she mentioned that these hunters
whether dark or shadow preserved the
balance between good and evil protecting
humans from being consumed or enslaved
then there was a publishing fiasco in
which Claire's publisher mistakenly
printed 100,000 copies of a Shadowhunter
book referencing the dark hunter mark on
the cover whoops
the show may get canceled Katherine
McNamara officially announced that she
had just finished shooting all of her
scenes in shadow hunters season 3 in
early May 2018 but she made it seem as
if she was unsure on whether or not they
would be back for season 4 on her
Instagram account
she wrote late night musings after
wrapping shadow hunter season 3 she
thanked everyone who helped pull off
another season and said it was a
pleasure and an honor to have such a
wonderful work family then she ended
with saying she is hoping to be back
soon we take it this means that free
form has yet to give a green light for
the next installment of the supernatural
fantasy series so if we did a little
investigating
it appears that season 3 is not doing so
hot in the ratings department as a
matter of fact season 3 is down in
ratings by about 40% compared to season
2 that's a pretty steep drop it's no
wonder Katherine seems a bit unsure as
it right now shadow hunters season 4 has
not been renewed but there is no news of
the show being cancelled either what do
you guys think should they cancel the
show Domenic is a big prankster dominic
sherwood may play a skilled soldier on
screen in his role of Jason
Shadowhunters but off screen he is just
a crazy prankster the biggest prankster
on the set apparently Kat McNamara said
he played a lot of pranks on her when
they were filming on set Kat revealed
that Dom's craziest prank was when he
taped her to her trailer she said she
doesn't really know how it happened but
she was standing on the trailer steps
and they were joking about something and
suddenly he was
keeping your hand to the stair railing
she said she was laughing too hard to do
anything about it
she said she was stuck standing there on
the steps when everyone came running but
she said they weren't running to help
her and cut her loose
they were running with their camera
phones to capture the hilarious prank
had said that luckily Matthew daddario
who plays Alec Lightwood on the show
took pity on her and set her free
she said she finally made it back to set
that was one of her favorite moments
from filming on set cultural
appropriation in maraud Tobia who plays
the role of Isabelle Lightwood found
herself in a bit of a controversy when
she posted a picture of her on vacation
in Thailand with her hair styled in long
braids her Twitter followers called him
rowed outs for cultural appropriation
and explains why her picture was
problematic but instead of apologizing
or even justifying the picture she
tweeted another picture of herself with
braids this definitely I did fuel to the
fire
one fan even tried to send Tobia a
direct message via Twitter respectfully
explaining why it was a problem Tobia
blocked the fan then she retweeted a fan
who said her braids were like those of
Christina Aguilera Jennifer Lopez and
Shakira then she posted a picture of her
as a little girl when her mom put a
bunch of braids in her hair
Emma Rhodes braids have been the source
of a heated debate one fan wrote that
she is black and is literally beyond
fine with however Amuro chooses to wear
her hair but other people argue that she
was disrespecting an entire culture so
what do you guys think is it okay for
her to get her hair braided like this or
is it cultural appropriation leave a
comment telling us what you think the
hook-up scene Twitter blew up after the
hookup scene between Magnus and Alec in
the scene Alec comes to see Magnus they
talk for a second then Alec takes Magnus
totally off guard when he grabs Magnus
and kisses him he asks what that was all
about and then jokes that he's not
complaining but wants to know Alec says
he wants to take the next step in their
relationship
Magnus shares that he is worried that if
they washed into hooking up you may lose
Alec Alec insists that they have nothing
to worry about and then kisses Magnus
again and pushes him into the bedroom
and that's when Twitter exploded many
fans were disheartened but Alec did not
get proper consent from Magnus before
pushing him into the bedroom they called
it dubious consents
that means that consent was uncertain or
not completely known fans were quick to
point out that consensual hookups are
hotter and they didn't like it when it
faded to black when hetero love scenes
are not Shadowhunters showrunner Darrin
Schwimmer responded to the backlash on
Twitter saying that the creator's
thought it was a given that alec
wouldn't have forced anything but a fair
point that they could have made
consensual clear on screen do you think
the fans have a fair point and that's it
for 10 dark secret Shadowhunters doesn't
want you to know thanks for watching the
things see you later
[Music]